Richard has the most interesting story
you know Richard is a legendary Kansas
City chief yeah his wife is a
Philadelphia Eagles fan and Richard gave
us some [__] on Wednesday about how
he's rooting for both teams because he
doesn't want his wife to be upset it was
a total [__]
um you know it was very funny because he
claimed you know he was going to be
happy for her no matter what if she won
and she would be happy for him but this
wasn't him whole new territory for them
as a couple they've never been in this
situation before Richard you said you
hated this Super Bowl because uh it's
been horrible can you describe some of
the horrible quality of this thing
Howard I didn't know what it was going
to be like until the game happened and
it was the worst Sports watching
experience I've had in my freaking life
like I mean your wife is as big a
Philadelphia Eagles fan as you are can't
like way bigger way bigger way big is
Hardcore and she was Ray pleased to be a
hardcore Eagles fan by her dad and her
grandfather and it means so much to her
and she didn't even want to look at me
when the game started she told me she's
like you got to go down to the basement
you got to get out of here like because
you're a Kansas City fan and in a way
she's being respectful she's like I
don't want to hear you cheering exactly
anyway here is the first touchdown that
the Eagles scored I was down in the
basement watching and I heard her
upstairs and then recorded wow listen to
this this is all the way from Richard's
basement
[Applause]
what is that banging noise
stomping her foot on the floor and joy
and happiness and I was like
foreign
[Applause]
she is absolutely perfect Howard and you
know what's funny too is the TV upstairs
was ahead of the TV downstairs so I hear
this and I'm like oh [__] the Eagles are
gonna score now ah what a horrible
experience like that even ruined to the
game it did it did it really I did not
like the feeling of us not being able to
celebrate together when when you sent us
to the Chiefs Super Bowl in 2020 she was
so supportive and War Chief's gear and
we were so happy together and then this
game like I couldn't cheer for the
Eagles and I wanted to so bad but I
can't because I [__] love the Chiefs
man and it tore me apart I hated it I
[__] hated it I don't ever want the
Chiefs and Eagles to play in the Super
Bowl against each other again and shut
your [__] mouth Sal you idiot hahaha
I know that's why I'm upset Richard was
down in his basement and I don't know
maybe you were with your wife at this
point this is where you know obviously I
was quietly celebrating by myself where
she couldn't hear me oh okay on the punt
return right
listen to Richard that was awesome all
right here it's so awesome but Richard
can't cheer even because his wife might
hear listen to this oh my God oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God look at
this
that road
again oh my God what a [__] run you
know it's weird I guarantee your wife
would have been celebrating if the
Eagles had won you know what I mean I
know she would have been as loud as she
was with that first touchdown yeah and I
would have sucked it up and celebrated
with her but you know it's she is way
more of a fan hardcore fan than I am
even she was so nice and supportive at
the end she was like she felt bad that
she couldn't be like let me have my
moment but I was like I understand like
her team just lost the Super Bowl it's
horrible this is another note Richard's
wife flipped over Richard's car and lit
it on fire
laughs
foreign